you know it's really hard to know how to
start an elden ring lore video because
lately for every bit of environmental
storytelling dialogue character
direction item description whatever it
may be i've been trying to connect it
all together but the lands between is
absolutely massive there is so much to
go over and research in this game that
it is overwhelming at times not to say
that i don't love doing it i definitely
do but to help me understand more of the
plot and hopefully all of you as well i
think we need to look at the source of
where the entire story stems from the
roots of all the cause and effect that
branches off in many many different
directions i believe all of it starts
from a sophisticated multi-dimensional
plan to destroy the golden order the two
fingers and the outer gods that has
spread its influence across the lands
between and infected the minds of the
people who live there this plan was
orchestrated by the most interesting and
eluding characters in all of elden rank
queen america and ronnie the witch while
seemingly opposites i believe these two
work together to take down the golden
order and what they both sought in this
in the lands between was change
before i get into the video i just want
to remind you to subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already as 90 of
people who watch my videos are not
actually subscribed yet just a month ago
this percentage was at 97 so it seems
like my cute dog plugs have been working
lately she's still getting tummy rubs
and treats for every new subscriber my
goal is to get this percentage down to a
50 50 split by the end of the year but
only subscribe if you like my content
and want to see more videos of elden
ringlor theories and of my dog which you
can also find on twitter and instagram
so with all that said thank you and
let's get into the video
i want to start with queen america and
her backstory leading up to the
shattering of the elden ring we know
that america is of the newman race from
the description of newman's rune which
reads the newman are said to have come
from outside the lands between and are
in fact of the same stock as queen
america herself what little more we can
learn about the newman race comes from
more item descriptions like the newman
race option in the character selection
screen and america's hammer which both
mention that the newman lands are from
outside the lands between and while they
are seldom born they live for an
extended period of time the most
interesting item description we can read
about the newmans comes from the black
knives set which reads the assassins
that carried out the deeds of the knight
of black knives were all women and
rumored to be newman who had close ties
with america herself what we can gather
from all of this information is that
queen america is of the newman race that
comes from an outside world the black
knives who are the assassins that
carried out the knight of black knives
are all of newman origin are all women
and have close ties with queen america
next i'd like to show you some dialogue
from roger that gives us more
information about the knight of black
knives you recall our conversation about
the knight of black knives yes they say
the assassins who carried out the deed
were scions of the eternal city a group
entirely of women arrayed in armor of
silver undercloaks which fooled the eye
the knives they wielded though were
imparted with the power of the rune of
death through sinister rights so this
basically tells us that the assassins
who carried out the knight of black
knives are newman but were likely born
in the eternal city could this tell us
more about what it actually means when
it says that the newmans are from
another world because the way this reads
would indicate that they're from another
world completely not just from the lands
between but another outer world in space
i believe this could be a mistranslation
between the english and japanese in-game
texts without going over the top in
detail when this description says outer
world this more likely is referring to a
foreign underground or spirit world is
this where these assassins get their
invisibility abilities from are these
assassins traversing in and out of the
spirit world at will to do this it kind
of reminds me of the spirit world from
avatar the last airbender where the
spirits could willingly traverse in and
out of the spirit world dimension i
don't think we know for sure at least at
this point in eldon ring's lifespan but
if you have a theory or more information
on this please let me know down in the
comments also i'm not saying that the
newmans originated from the eternal city
but eventually settled there after the
civilization that built the city
collapsed the point of all of this is
that all of these outer worldly origins
could be why the greater will chose
queen america to become their
representative god we know that the
greater will does not exist in the
physical world of the lands between as
we see it as the player it uses vessels
like the two fingers and its followers
to impact and spread the influence of
the golden order it can also create a
manifestation of itself such as the
elden beast to carry out its will when
all else fails with all of the other
outer worldly creatures that we know
exist outside of our world like the
astial beans the falling star beasts the
all bastards it's definitely not a
stretch to think the newman race and
queen america would also have similar
origins and abilities so what triggered
america to shatter the elden ring there
are many theories as to why she would do
this did she do it to just test the
power of the greater will to destroy it
just defy it well in my opinion they
tell us why she did it right from the
start of the game
soon
america's offspring demigods all
[Music]
claimed the shines
of the elden ring
[Music]
the mad taint of their newfound strength
triggered the shattering the mad taint
can be defined as to sully or tarnish a
reputation many people think that the
demigods received their great runes
after the shattering like these runes
were dispersed randomly and all of these
demigod children of america received
their runes after the shattering based
on the wording from the opening
cinematic it seems like the demigods
were given their great runes before all
of this started but because of their
newfound strength created from their
great runes it caused some if not all of
the demigod children to seek more power
this was likely the intention of the
greater will as it would lead to more
battles in war that the urgery would
grow stronger off of as i've discussed
in several videos already the erd tree
feeds on struggle it needs the people of
the lands between to battle and create
war in order to spread its power and
influence lord godfrey was amongst these
battles with his own army but over time
they ran out of enemies to fight against
with no more battles being waged came a
time where there was limited struggle
and the urgery grew weaker over time
godfrey and his men lost their guidance
of grace from the greater will this
sullied the reputation of the golden
order and queen america's family in
order to combat this queen america
banished godfrey and his men outside of
the lands between to wage war to live
and to die
in america's own words
my lord
and thy warriors
i divest each of thee
of thy grace
with thine eyes dimmed
ye will be driven from the lands between
ye will wage war in a land afar
where ye will live
and die this event would be known as the
long march of the tarnished along with
this america would order malaketh to
seal the rune of death away so that
everyone in the lands between would live
die and continue to struggle feeding the
urgery for all of eternity with destined
death sealed into maliket's black blade
now as i hope we all know at this point
america and ratagon are the same person
just with two different conscious minds
america needed a consort to take the
role of elden lord in place of godfrey
it is not known how ratagon came to be
whether he was once his own individual
man or was just manifested by the
greater will or even manifested by queen
america herself that can be its own
video in the future but what we do know
is that radagon is america and he became
known as the second elden lord before
godfrey and the rest of his tarnish
warriors were sent away to battle in a
faraway land ratagon was sent to fight
against the carrion royal empire and its
leader queen ranala of the full moon
while they met on the battlefield
ratagan and ranala fell in love and went
on to have three children reichard radon
and ronnie all three of these children
could have eventually been chosen by the
two fingers to one day succeed america
and become the empyrean queen of the
golden order and a vessel for the
greater will however ronnie was the one
chosen to be her successor it isn't
known why she was chosen over her two
brothers at this time but in light of
what took place meaning reichard feeding
himself to the god devouring snake and
radon being infected with the scarlet
rot it seems in hindsight that the two
fingers chose wisely we know that ronnie
did not want to become queen so she
devised a plan to discard her empyrean
flesh and her great rune to never be
subject to the bidding of the two
fingers forgive mine intrusion tarnished
i doubt we shall again meet
[Music]
but all the same
learn well the lands between
how long will it be i wonder
before the tarnished tire of a basins to
the two fingers in order to do this
ronnie needed to complete a ritual how
this ritual works we don't know much
about what we do know is that it
involves the rune of death in one
demigod dying in spirit while another
would kill their body what we can assume
is that the fragment of the rune of
death was stolen from malakath how it
was stolen is mostly unknown and we can
make plenty of theories on that but it's
heavily implied that ronnie got a hold
of it somehow in my opinion i believe
america helped steal this fragment for
ronnie as suggested in the black blade
remembrance reading malakath was a
shadow bound beast given to his imperium
america's sole need for her shadow was a
vessel to lock away destined death even
then she betrayed him i believe that
this betrayal could be her stealing that
fragment of the rune of death from
malacath if you want even more info on
this part in particular go check out my
video on the glomide queen and destined
death but why would merika steal this
fragment for ronnie what reason does she
have to help her well this is where i
believe her entire plan starts to become
clearer to us queen america always had
plans to oppose the greater will and
needs elements that oppose the greater
will to help her malakath was given to
merica by her own two fingers in order
to serve her and the greater will if any
imperian was known by their shadow to do
anything to defy the greater will then
their shadow would turn on them the two
fingers gave blithe to ladyrani as a
faithful follower her very shadow
incapable of treachery
but if lady rani
as an empirian resists being an
instrument of the two fingers
the shadow will go mad
transforming from a follower
into a horrid curse
but such is his destiny
in such matters blythe's own thoughts
hold no weight
it pains me so
but he must be neutralized
america needed malakath out of the
picture so she sent him to pharaoh
missoula to seal away destined death
next she needed godfrey and his warriors
out of the picture so she took away
their guidance of grace and banished
them from the lands between without
godfrey and his warriors to fight back
defying the greater will would be a much
easier endeavor next she needed more
allies that would oppose the greater
will along with her so she sent ratagan
to battle against ranala whether she
knew they would fall in love or just has
the power to control ratagon while he's
in the state of being again because they
are the same person is unknown to us
what we do know is that the result of
this relationship was an ally for queen
america's plan
ronnie america knew that if she forced
radagon to return to the urgery to
become the second elden lord after
banishing godfrey rinala would likely
start to despise queen america we know
she holds this grudge against her
because if you look around raya lucaria
academy where we fight against and meet
ranala there are absolutely no statues
of queen america to be found while the
rest of the lands between are filled
with them we also hear from muriel our
super cute turtle pope that ranala
became heartbroken after ratagon left
her you wish to know more of lady ranala
she is queen
head of the karyan royal family
and governor of the academy of real
lucaria
the great and beautiful full moon witch
sadly her heart was broken when lord
radigan left her
and then
when the academy rebelled against the
royals
she was locked away in the grand library
now of course it would have been
impossible for queen america to know if
ronnie would eventually defy the golden
order and go along with her plan it's a
long shot to assume that she carefully
crafted relationships with certain
people to influence ronnie's eventual
decision we know that george rr martin
loves to write stories this way but in
the end ronnie did wish to defy it and
went along perfectly with america's plan
now this next part is where it gets a
little dicey with people did queen
america know that ronnie would kill
godwin's soul in order to complete the
ritual of the knight of black knives and
have ronnie be rid of her empyrean flesh
in my opinion i believe america did know
this she banished her own husband
godfrey from the lands between to die
she sentenced her own half-brother
malaketh to seal away the rune of death
for reasons unknown to him that defied
the greater will she hid two of her
children morgot and moog in the sewers
below the capital city because of their
omen birth defects now this was likely
at the request of the greater will and
its customs potentially but she did it
nonetheless as sad as it is to say i
don't think it's too far of a stretch
that america would allow ronnie to kill
godwin for the sake of their plan we
don't know much about godwin before the
knight of black knives what we can
assume just from the given title as
godwin the golden is that he was a
valuable asset to the golden order he
would have been against queen america's
plan we can take from all of this
information which i should remind you is
mainly speculation at this point that
queen america let ronnie use godwin to
complete her ritual and kill her
imperial flesh removing her from the
influence of the two fingers this ritual
was known as the knight of black knives
where daggers imbued with the fragment
of the rune of death were pierced into
ronnie and godwin at the same time this
killed ronnie's body leaving just her
spirit to roam free as she wished and
this also killed godwin's spirit leaving
only his lifeless body behind queen
america always knew that she would
shatter the elden ring the success of
this plan as we've discussed depended on
many different variables going according
to plan and up to this point in the
timeline everything has gone according
to plan for the most part ronnie waited
for queen america to set the final act
of their plan into motion queen america
knew that the shattering would cause
defiance of the greater will her other
half ratagon for wars between many
different factions and her demigod
children and it would mean the return of
the tarnished to the lands between this
was the culmination of her entire plan
for us the tarnished to return to the
lands between and have a choice to make
a choice that would determine the future
of quite literally everything she knew
that we would struggle she knew we'd be
manipulated by many different characters
she knew we'd have difficult choices to
make she knew that we'd have to kill her
own children and she knew that we'd
eventually have to kill her all of this
didn't matter because no matter what
path we decide to go down no matter what
ending that we choose it would lead to
what she wanted it would lead to change
a change that would test the faith of
everyone in the lands between it would
eventually lead to the strongest
becoming the new elden lord as we come
down to the end godfrey is met with the
same destiny as we are he knows the
struggle we have endured as he's endured
it himself does godfrey know america's
plan probably not he just knows as much
as we do as fellow tarnished we must
mend the elden ring but america gave us
a choice to mend it in any way we see
fit after we defeat godfrey he
complements our strength and goes down
honorably in defeat
faith
tarnished
my strength
this line by godfrey seems to be the
theme of america's plan the strongest
survive she started to harbor doubts
against the greater will and wanted to
test its strength through this
complicated plan that she orchestrated
ronnie's ending brings up the weaknesses
of the greater will
here making it the chill night that
encompasses all
reaching the great beyond
into fear
doubt
and loneliness when ronnie says this
she's referring to how the golden order
did not allow the people of the lands
between to feel any of these emotions
the greater will controlled everyone's
faith their own thoughts their emotions
under ronnie's ending or better known as
the age of the stars ronnie will allow
everyone to feel as they feel they can
decide for themselves what they wish to
feel believe and think it allows them
freedom and a great change was needed to
be rid of the greater will and usher in
a new era one that will last 1 000 years
under the wisdom of the full moon this
freedom of change is exactly what
america wanted for her people and
intertwines into ronnie's ending almost
perfectly but ultimately the ending was
up to us this was our own journey that
housed our own path decisions doubts and
struggles as a tarnished america let us
decide the fate of the world just as she
had planned from the very start
you all for watching the video i really
hope you enjoyed it this was very much
my most ambitious video yet so leave a
like and subscribe if you'd like to see
more have a great rest of your day and
i'll see you all in the next video take
care
[Music]